c'est un grand honneur de venir parce
que parce que parce que c'est une grande
star qui a eu également de gros
problèmes avec l'alcool elle va nous en
parler bien sûr le récap dont je
plaisantais bien sûr c'est Anne
Roumanoff qu'on reçoit tout de suite
elle râle à tout de suite merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
devenu dans les années 2000 une figure
médiatique incontournable elle enchaîne
les expériences réussies à la radio
moi-même qui suis considéré comme
quelqu'un qui a réussi dans le milieu de
l'humour et du mannequinat
ou à la télévision moi les mecs de mes
copines ne m'intéressent absolument pas
après tout ce qu'elles m'ont raconté sur
eux à 57 ans aujourd'hui l'humoriste
n'est pas près de prendre sa retraite et
va continuer de nous faire rire grâce à
son humour corrosif et à son regard
lucide sur la société mais toi même
[Musique]
je reçois Anne Roumanoff c'est fou la
meuf elle a tourné des Zéniths
je reçois une star j'aimerais juste
d'abord vous remercier et raconter en
deux secondes le début de notre histoire
un jour l'ancien Mathieu c'est lui que
j'appelle le con
écoute Europe 1 je sais pas ça ne fait
pas tellement rire et je tweet qui est
une idée de faire venir Anne Roumanoff
sur Europe 1 oh là là dans le quart
d'heure je reçois un tweet d'Anne
Roumanoff qui répond certainement
quelqu'un qui s'est rendu compte que
depuis ça fait plus 30% sur chaque quart
d'heure
et fin de l'histoire j'avais oublié ça
et merde tu restes là ou pas
je pars en vacances je vais en vacances
dans le sud petit restaurant tout mignon
je vous explique les tables en terrasse
c'est c'est 30 cm je me mets là avec un
camarade à 30 cm donc je fais juste ça
on est là Anne Roumanoff après
2 je demande à changer de PLACE petit
trois je ne sais pas et le petit 3 qui
s'est passé c'est que je suis tombé sur
une femme adorable on est devenu amis et
j'ai découvert que derrière l'artiste il
y avait celle que je vais montrer
maintenant c'est une femme que j'adore
on entend 11 février dernier classement
vous êtes la 9e humoriste préférée des
français et je précise que sur le top 10
il y en a que deux c'est Florence
forestier et vous qu'est-ce que ça vous
a fait les femmes ça fait plaisir mais
[Musique]
non mais il faut qu'on fait en vérité
faut pas enfin être artiste c'est pas
les classements c'est aussi le non mais
c'est le lien avec le public c'est
surtout ça qui est important en fait
alors justement liens que public c'est
on va en parler aussi parce que vous
avez fait beaucoup beaucoup de scène
beaucoup beaucoup de spectacles vous
avez fait trois Olympiens aussi dans un
qui était au cinéma à un moment donné je
me suis fait ça c'est dur de remplir 3
Olympiens c'est 2000 personnes à chaque
fois on le dit pas mais la plupart des
stars souvent le font qu'une fois et à
moitié c'est les invités le public a
toujours toujours été là avec vous et
alors moi je vous ai vu en spectacle qui
est très drôle ça a beaucoup changé
parce que maintenant vous tapez un peu
et vous faites monter des gens sur scène
et je me demandais c'est comme les
mentalistes est-ce que vous repérez un
peu avant vous les regardez vous savez
ou quoi ou pas parce que si ça se passe
mal si de rien s'il est pas drôle c'est
le risque parce que les pauvres ils ont
rien demandé mais c'est vrai que je non
je le fais au feeling c'est à dire
vraiment genre dans la salle et tout
d'un coup je choisis quelqu'un et
parfois après je des hommes et si c'est
trop galère je le fais descendre
clairement vous écoutez un peu vous
découvrir
ez
le 31 décembre à Deauville et le
monsieur a demandé sa femme mon mariage
enfin c'était pas sa femme si en direct
donc c'est super quoi et vous vous êtes
jamais un petit coup de cœur pour
quelqu'un qui avait monté sur scène
comme une amie m'a dit et son mari non
jamais non une fois il y a un mec qui
m'a écrit mais non
[Rires]
non mais c'était il y a très longtemps
moi je sais pas mais que j'avais fait
monter je sais pas il a eu j'étais celui
qui est monté sur cette
d'accord très bien alors ce que j'ai
adoré avec vous j'ai eu qu'un interview
vraiment je vous le dis c'est une
admiration bon vous semble parce que
vous le dites vous avez
j'ai essayé de dire bien tout ce que
vous avez tenté au début vous avez
échoué mais peu importe vous a fermé la
porte et vous êtes rentrés pas la
fenêtre et vous avez fini par réussir
tout alors que 50000 personnes auraient
abandonné et c'est c'est hallucinant
vous avez fait Sciences Po d'abord
pardon mais bonjour madame ah ouais bah
oui quand même avec un an d'avance de
toute façon pour avoir de l'humour ça va
être très intelligent exactement sinon
en général sinon ça donne de l'humour
nouveau talon du rire rire et chansons
souvent
non mais c'est vrai donc très bonne en
classe et déjà petite vous rêviez de
faire ça à partir de 8-10 ans vous
rêviez d'être actrice en fait c'est ça
et vous faisiez des imitations et donc
là vous voyez venir
vous y mettez très bien Sylvie jolie
la porte on aurait dit un genre de
m'entraîneur africain je vous dis mais
ce
qui c'est peut-être ma fiancé qu'obé son
parapluie quelque chose entre parents
je me suis dit bon j'ai de lac d'accord
c'est pas grand chose mais en attendant
je pourrai appeler
Sylvie faut rappeler que Sylvie elle a
inspirée malade
un très bon ami j'adore
vous avez sur un secret je vous le
passage moi tout simplement
[Applaudissements]
à l'école elle dit leurs yeux brillaient
j'en ai presque gêné
et ses petits-enfants disaient mais
c'est votre grande sœur qui va vous
chercher les pauvres ces petits chameaux
alors vous passez une audition en
Amérique du 13e j'avance un petit peu et
c'est Guy Lux qui vous appelle le
lendemain vous pensez l'avoir raté comme
d'habitude je dégoût passé une édition
vous sortez vous pleurez vous pleurez
beaucoup vos petites HPE
[Rires]
c'était le lancement de la classe il
cherchait des humoristes et ils avaient
passé des messages à l'antenne donc
c'était vraiment une audition ouverte à
tout le monde et ce qui fait marrer
c'est que j'arrive Guy luxe donc c'est
la classe
il y avait est-ce que le malade Palmade
il y avait des noms incroyables il y
avait Michel Laroque mais sinon en fille
avec vous en vrai on a tendance à se
dire ça devait être génial non vous
dites c'était pas l'ambiance de fou non
c'est pas ça c'est que c'était dur moi
j'ai un an avant j'étais à Sciences Po
c'était pas tout à fait la même ambiance
et je me suis retrouvé à 22 ans avec des
gens qui étaient quand même plus âgés
une ambiance un peu de cabaret à la
queue comme ça
les gens de Sciences Po il me disait
mais vraiment hein
je t'ai vu à la télé mais tu as intégré
cette émission enfin c'était ah non
avant j'étais en bibliothèque avec un
certain sur la tête en train de lire le
monde et je me retrouve là et là on voit
la fille vraiment qui veut réussir vous
vous dites il doit avoir des méthodes
vous achetez des bouquins américains
comment faire rire comment faire du
sport
c'est à dire enfin c'était des bouquins
de conseils et notamment il conseille
d'envoyer son CV ou sa photo directeur
du casting toutes les semaines et je le
faisais un jour j'ai rencontré quelqu'un
il m'a dit j'ai 600 photos de toi
j'étais un peu j'étais certainement
volontaire sans doute un peu trop mais
voilà c'est une nature un peu et après
vous êtes dur avec vous parce que vous
dites j'ai fait plein de choses à chaque
fois que j'ai fait des choses par
exemple bah j'ai voulu faire un film
avec Claude Lelouch et globalement j'ai
fait des essais et pour jouer le rôle
d'une fille moche
j'ai fait des essais à l'époque c'était
avec Vincent Lindon mais on vous appelle
vraiment pour vous dire on cherche une
fille moche ou un an avec un
après on m'appelle pour une pub c'était
une pub pour euh
[Musique]
on m'a dit on hésite entre un
je fais c'était
homo et en fait ils ont pris un stage
en fait c'était pas une actrice c'était
un saint
et il faut dire il faut dire très
honnêtement pendant des années vous
remplissez toutes les salles et c'est
vrai qu'on ne voit pas tellement la télé
il y avait ce petit côté alors est-ce
que c'est parce que vous êtes une femme
ou quoi il y avait ce petit côté un peu
populaire un peu ringard vous aviez pas
la carte ce qu'on appelle un peu la
carte aujourd'hui des beaux douces des
machins c'est pas
fallait on appelait pas Roumanoff pour
un film et tout ça est-ce que ça au
début vous en souffriez de remplir des
salles mais de sentir que dans les
Molières les machins les petits mieux
parisiens vous n'existez pas beaucoup
oui oui
mais en fait peut-être que ça vient de
moi aussi en fait je sais pas pourquoi
parce que
je pense que j'ai non
j'ai une névrose de rejet en fait mais
c'est un truc qui vient de mes ancêtres
quand on vous dit on vous dit bonjour du
va te faire non pardon va te
faire c'est pas ça c'est que dans
ma famille non mais après c'est
psychanalytique mais j'ai beaucoup
je suis toujours là qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé pour demain enfin bon bref c'est
ça un travail sur moi et ça peut venir
ça vient de soi aussi
ça vient de moi
et maintenant ça va mieux j'ai de
sentiments vous êtes c'est aussi
j'ai le sentiment que à part vous avez
divorcé tout ça ça a été dire je à 50
ans vous avez divorcé la banane était
pour Anne oui mais elle me l'a elle me
la renvoie j'ai le sentiment que vous
avez divorcé à 50 ans il y a eu un
virage dans votre vie il y a eu 2007
Michel Drucker ou tout d'un coup on
prend conscience d'abord que vous faites
de la politique que vous écrivez très
bien que ça cartonne le petit milieu
parisien on va dire bobo j'aime pas dire
ça s'intéresse à vous vous divorcez
aussi à 50 ans
il y a une deuxième vie qui commence
c'est vrai c'est vrai pourquoi
non mais je pense que la vie c'est un
chemin donc avoir un but faire ceci
faire cela c'est intéressant mais
finalement quand on vieillit ce qui
compte c'est le chemin et c'est c'est
d'évoluer de s'améliorer d'être mieux
dans sa peau voilà c'est pas que la
carrière en fait aujourd'hui vous êtes
au top de du club non pas du tout
j'espère c'est un chemin la vie donc
j'espère être encore mieux dans
quelques-uns enfin voilà je vous avais
un petit camarade
c'est très important d'être amoureux
c'est parce que j'ai pas entendu la je
pense que ça veut dire oui comme vous
avez de très jolie on sait plus ce que
vous dites
ça veut dire oui non
tu seras pas mais
vous êtes très heureuse en tout cas moi
j'ai juste vu votre fille qui est
magnifique ça c'est tout ce que je
voulais dire voilà qu'est-ce que tu as
besoin de petit quart d'heure non moi
j'étais très impressionné par la
carrière de Anne je savais pas que vous
allez jouer au Maroc en Tunisie aux
États-Unis bientôt votre première à
Abidjan ça va être votre grande première
là-bas comment vous comment vous allez
le gérer bah c'est j'aime bien les jouer
à l'étranger j'ai joué cet été j'ai joué
à New York et à Miami et c'est vrai que
c'est excitant et c'est différent vous
arrivez à fédérer et à remplir les
salles dans ces pays autres que la
France par les Français
c'est des petites salles c'est les
grandes salles parce que ici vous faites
des sales monstrueuses mais du coup
là-bas ça doit être plus intimiste c'est
pas plus impressionnant pas à New York
c'est ça qui est excitant c'est de se
remettre en cause et de de faire des
choses nouvelles qu'on a encore jamais
fait parce que oui est-ce que je peux
dire une dernière chose parce que comme
on a passé comme on a passé quelques
jours ensemble dans le sud c'est vrai à
Noël je le vois au bord de la piscine
bah oui j'étais en train de nager il est
là
vous avez pas vu vous avez pas vu que
c'était mon visage j'étais là je sors un
peu de la piscine elle doit être
arrivé et tu m'as dit et vous m'avez dit
est-ce qu'on peut prendre un verre
d'eau ça va n'importe quoi et étonnant
j'ai une question je dis encore lui j'ai
une question
c'est ma dernière question c'est ma
dernière question quand on a dîné
ensemble vous m'avez dit un truc qui m'a
beaucoup touchée ça fait des années que
je voulais être actrice je veux monter
mon film je le ferai pour l'instant on
compte pas tellement sur moi au cinéma
parce que les producteurs sont
compliqués et même il y a des acteurs
parfois quand j'en parle il répond pas
parce que on répond pas ah non Manoff
c'est pas une femme de cinéma et tout ça
c'est encore très dur c'est misogyne
tout ça je sais que le film vous ferait
parce que vous êtes toujours fait ce que
vous voulez voilà vous en êtes où et
c'est que le rapport que le cinéma on en
est où ben ça avance mais c'est sûr que
c'est sûr qu'on m'attend pas au cinéma
et
c'est sûr que je pense que si j'étais un
homme mais après c'est pas grave mais
c'est vrai que il y a quand même très
peu de femmes réalisatrices il y a très
peu de femmes de 50 ans à l'image au
cinéma et que faut que vous lui a
proposé
en tous les cas on peut vous voir ou en
ce moment demain je suis enfin ce soir
je suis à Saint-Chamond et je joue à
Marseille à Toulouse à Abid
et moi je peux vous dire vraiment je
peux vous dire vraiment j'étais voir le
spectacle je savais pas du tout ce que
j'allais voir et j'ai halluciné ces
rythme mais c'est en fait c'est le
spectacle de quelqu'un qui a vraiment
vraiment 20 ans de scène et qui sait qui
sait faire 35 ans ou j'étais gentil ah
oui sur C8 d'ailleurs ils sont très
bientôt sur C8 il y aura les 35 carrière
avec plein d'invités là je suis désolé
on n'a pas pu voir les extraits parce
que ça remontage mais sachez que si le
public vous aime moi également merci
beaucoup Adriana
[Musique]
et je sais qu'elle aime pas venir en
plateau c'est une artiste